alain bruneel merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france le nord placée
sous couvre-feu désormais comment avez
vous réagi à cette annonce
moi j'aime bien je m'y attendais j'avoue
que je m'y attendais puisque la pandémie
progresse le virus circule et donc le
nord d'abord c'était la métropole
lilloise donc qui était nouveau feu
maintenant c'est tout le département
c'était plus de 600 communes quand même
donc à la fois rural est à la fois
urbaine
ce qui veut dire que la situation est
grave je vais dire aussi que des mesures
sont prises parce que la question est la
suivante est ce que les hôpitaux bon
pouvoir faire face donc aux arrivées de
différents malades au niveau des
urgences est justement selon vous est ce
que la france a les moyens humains et
matériels
ouvrir de nouveaux lits aujourd'hui la
france a les moyens
moi ce que je regrettais ça fait plus de
deux ans que personnel soignant se
mobiliser cri d alerte en disant il
manque du personnel manque de moyens
dans les hôpitaux mais malheureusement
on écoute par ailleurs en demi et à ce
qui nous arrive aujourd'hui
depuis le mois de mars avait sept mois
et depuis sept mois et aucune des idéaux
qui étaient prises notamment pour
embaucher du personnel et notamment
parce que à chaque fois qu'on ouvre un
lit de réanimation ces trois personnes
pour 12 heures ça fait six personnes
pour 24 heures mais sans doute pas fait
on n'a pas entamé de sardines vraiment
2005 il manque de spécialistes mais il
faut former aussi les gens donc aux
recettes pour ne plus former des
infirmières voilà c'est ça la question
d'un peu aujourd'hui aussi des aides
soignantes
on aurait pu aussi anticiper on n'a pas
anticipé alors on a cinq mille huit
cents lits qui sont aujourd'hui en
réanimation en france qui représente un
peu plus de 35% de parts d'heuliez
occupé mais on aurait dû ouvrir 12 min
ce qu'est ce tu es engagé le
gouvernement 12 min ça fait vingt-quatre
mille 1 terminée et 10000 personnel en
la soignant la perspective d'un
confinement aujourd'hui vous inquiète
c'est d'abord c'est inquiétant ça veut
dire qu'on a tous les dispositifs qui
ont été pris on a échoué
ça veut dire que dans les différences
positives et en même temps j'ai
l'impression que j'ai plus l'impression
ces cas une incohérence regardez ici on
dit qu'elle couvre feu sur lui métropole
maintenant s'est élargie à plusieurs
départements et en même temps on dit
tout le monde peut partir en vacances
ça me paraît un peu compliquée quoi ça
me paraît un peu bizarre ça me paraît
incohérent donc on va dire aux gens qui
sont déjà peut-être atteindre ducobu 19
qui le savent pas encore bon partir en
vacances donc contaminés on permet une
circulation beaucoup plus rapide dessus
du virus c'est ça qui m'inquiète moi
donc il faut quand même rond au
contraire réussissent plus longtemps là
on a un gouvernement on était donc sur
un régime transitoire où on passe
maintenant
sur un état d'urgence sanitaire kim a
discuté à l'assemblée nationale samedi
et on va avec cette discussion donc le
gouvernement lui propose qu'on soit en
état d'urgence sanitaire jusqu'au mois
de février donc quatre mois quatre mois
et ensuite on juste qu'on 21 avril pour
discuter d'un régime transitoire mais on
ait eu les députés sont même plus
invitée à disputer à donner leur point
de vue est aussi à mettre en place un
plan d'urgence sanitaire on n'évacue
tous ces des urgences et
gouvernementales c'est normal il faut
qu'ils les prennent
mais à un moment donné le ton qu'on dit
stop on s'arrête et qu'on dit qu'est ce
qu'ils font quand on parle de lits de
réanimation
on lit toujours m'écouter on a fait ce
qu'il faut et on a préparé nos lits on a
préparé le personnel on peut y faire
face ce n'est pas vrai il va ouvrir
parce que tous les soigneurs aux
services qu'ils disent et soignants
d'avoir les soignants disent que le
couvre feu c'est bien parce que les gens
diront n'a pas simplement parce qu'en
fait elle pas submergés enfin on n'en
sait rien puisque combien de circulation
aussi des voyages qui vont pas voir
partir d'un département ou d'une région
et notre argent
ça doit aussi peut-être créer des cas de
coheed peut-être plus facilement
puisqu'on va faire circuler beaucoup
plus les gens bons et à partir de là on
n'a pas forcément les moyens nécessaires
parce que des soignants ai dit vous
savez la deuxième vague sera beaucoup
plus dur que la première vague on est
moins en moins de personnel les 8es
démission par exemple dans la région des
hauts de france et 892 infirmiers et
infirmières qu'ils ont démissionné qui
sont plus dans les hôpitaux parce que
les soignants dit on veut plus revivre
cette situation c'est ça qui est
dramatique c'est qu'on a pas les hôpital
on n'a pas tiré de leçons alors c'est
cette mesure de couvre feu ne fait pas
l'unanimité notamment auprès des
restaurateurs est ce que l'aide étatique
qui a été dévoilé à la hauteur selon
vous pour le pôle est oui alors ça ça
devient compliqué parce que là peut-être
la meilleure en 1° c'est mon point de
vue je pense que les restaurateurs et
les bars il avait pris les mesures
sanitaires mesures sanitaires qui qui
qui qui qui me permettait simplement aux
citoyens qui voient là le reste aurait
notamment dans les bars de ne pas
rappeler le coc vide voilà ne pas faire
ce que le coach
aujourd'hui on
tout est fermé et donc en même temps si
tout est fermé ça veut dire que calculée
ou catégories de population et de
jeunesse qu'elle va dire maintenant on a
besoin de se retrouver
donc ils vont faire la fête dans un tel
cas le domaine car elles vont se
retrouver plusieurs c'est ça qui va pas
il ya toujours des décisions qui sont
prises comme salt drastiques on va faire
ceci va faire cela et en même temps
mesurent pas les conséquences alors
effectivement on va redonner aux barges
pour aller bloquer un million un million
d'euros que je crois un peu plus d'un
milliard d'euros pour les bars et les
restaurants
mais c'est bah c'est pas ça qui va on ne
sait pas ça qui va en créer une
dynamique veut financière et économique
dans le pays est pas ça on est toujours
en train de le pallier aux conséquences
si on va s'attaquer aux causes
il faut s'attaquer à la cause voilà
alors jean castex a appelé tous les
citoyens français à télécharger la
nouvelle application tous sentis chaos
vide est ce que vous le ferez bah oui
évidemment je le ferai mais donc la
première application de façon à la vraie
été efficace la pomme n'a pas forcément
marcher il ya pas beaucoup de monde qui
se sont mis à me cette application sur
leur téléphone mais en même temps voilà
c'est pas quelques je pense que c'est
pas seulement ce à quoi il ya quelque
chose qui fonctionne pas voilà quelque
chose vaut cependant ce dans ce pays je
pense aussi qu'il fallait beaucoup dans
la recherche
parce que là on est du genre à dire on
va vivre avec le colis de lakovic 19 on
va user commis 19 donc il faut
s'habituer avec moi je prends m'habituer
à divac la copie 10h jeu qu'on puisse
enrayer cette crise ne je vous remets
d'aider des médecins et des chercheurs
là dessus alors se voit qu'ils aiment
dire il ya eu des milliards à des
millions ils ont été donnés dans
différents pays qui cherchent un peu
comme on veut faire un vaccin pour
contre je virus mais je pense qu'on est
dans un monde
on va vivre de plus en plus
malheureusement pareil comme ça de virus
qui vont circuler si on fait pas face
aujourd'hui à ça et qu'on anticipe pas
ça et lui reproche que lapentti 6 p ce
virus qui t'arrive merci beaucoup alain
bruneel d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes député pcf de
la 16e
circonscription du nord